the Trump administration has been one
exercise in projection after another
Hillary was going to get us into Wars
but it's actually Trump considering
military action over the last two years
in North Korea in Iran in Venezuela
actually taking action in Syria Hillary
was going to end up in prison for all of
her crimes except that it's actually
Trump associates ending up in prison and
it's Trump who's under more than 12 or
15 I don't even know the number
investigations at this point
Hillary used private email well half of
trumps staff has been caught using
private email at this point
Hillary mishandled classified and secret
information except Trump spilled secrets
to a Russian spy recruiter in the Oval
Office secrets that we learned from
another ally of ours and now it
continues
Donald Trump has exposed the location
and identities of members of Navy SEAL
Team 5 on Twitter you might recall that
Donald Trump had never been to visit
troops stationed in combat zones for
nearly two years of his presidency this
is something that previous presidents
did routinely Trump didn't do it and we
heard from a senior White House official
that Trump wasn't doing it merely
because he was afraid of getting killed
which gets us to yesterday on day five
of the government shutdown that Trump
caused in the midst of a spiraling
presidency Donald Trump decided to show
up in a combat zone news of the trip was
kept sort of quiet to maintain safety in
Iraq which is where Donald Trump went
that's fine so step one is that Trump
asked to take a picture with Lieutenant
Commander Q Lee who's the chaplain of
SEAL Team 5 which reveals that SEAL team
5 which is a very sensitive military
team was at the Al Asad Air Base in
western Iraq not ideal but okay this is
just the chaplain we don't know exactly
who else is part of this group or
anything about it but then Donald Trump
leaves Iraqi airspace and posts a video
to Twitter of him and Melania standing
for pictures with multiple members of
SEAL Team 5 we're supposed to keep the
locations of Special Forces secret
were supposed to keep the identities of
Special Forces secret a Department of
Defense official said to Newsweek that
quote even during Special Ops
demonstrations for congressional
delegations or for the president or vice
president personnel either have their
faces covered or their faces are
digitally blurred prior to anything
being released to the general public
that didn't happen
Trump has revealed the identities of
some of the people that our enemies
would most like to target and even if
you disagree with the missions
undertaken by our military and I
disagree with many of the missions
undertaken by our military they didn't
sign up to have the president tweet
unblurred pictures of their faces on the
Internet Trump spilling secrets in the
Oval Office using an unsecured iPhone
which we suspect foreign powers have
been working to intercept and may have
successfully intercepted and now he
exposes the faces which lead of course
to their names and the location of SEAL
Team 5 members any foreign Intel agency
that has the technological level of
development that China has would be able
to start back tracking the movements of
some of these individuals but to figure
out using CCTV and other footage what
have they been up to where have these
individuals been Trump is outing some of
the most sensitive military operators
and Pat it's all to make himself feel
alpha and big and strong
it's the publishing of sensitive data
that's a threat to national security
legally he's not liable anything the
president wants to make public he can
make public and it's effectively
declassified but this is an entire trip
during a government shutdown to get
Trump somewhere where he can brag about
how great and brave he is and he exposes
high-level military operatives yeah this
should not happen we need to pass laws
to make sure that it doesn't happen and
there should be more safeguards in place
the president shouldn't just be able to
take a video and post it directly to his
iPhone I'd like to see more people
handle the video first before it goes
out to the public I remember there was
much to do about Obama giving up his
blackberry when he became President
Elect back
Oh eight oh nine and I guess he did
willingly give the phone up if we made
it it sounded as if they were forcing
him to but apparently he could have kept
it if he wanted to
Obama sacrificed his Blackberry knowing
that it would be good for the country
and and safe for the country if he did
so Trump would not ever in a million
years consider doing that you have to
force him into it
and I don't like sanitized social media
use by elected officials but this is an
example of why maybe you do need lawyers
to manage the social media of the
president because this is an absolute
and utter atrocity send me your thoughts
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show
second-to-last show of 2018 one of the
day's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy com icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which
happens all the time it is all
completely free all you have to do is
click the link under this video to get
started and for a limited time they're
giving everyone in our audience $5
towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link